- [Announcer] Now you can
own all of Steve Williams'
wholesome country music
songs including hits
like this little ditty
about Steve's pet rooster.
♪ I'm in the barn, I'm
playin' with my cock
♪ All the boys line
up to pet my cock
♪ He's thick, he's red,
he's got a big old head
♪ Why don't I just
show you instead
♪ Raise your hand if
you wanna see my cock
- [Announcer] Yes,
they're all here.
♪ Riding the baloney pony
♪ I'll be walking
funny for a week
♪ That big old baloney pony
♪ Feels good between my cheeks
♪ You say love is easy
♪ But love is painful
♪ But love can make you cry
♪ But love can leave you bloody
- [Announcer] The
cowboys love this one.
♪ It's my first farm hand job
♪ Got it from a feller named Bob
♪ Shuckin' that corn on the cob
- [Announcer] This little
ditty about Tom Pedro
rode Steve's donkey
without a saddle.
♪ Pedro's going
bareback on my ass
- [Announcer] Music the
whole family can enjoy.
♪ Come in my back door, Bubba
♪ It's always open wide
♪ If you're gonna come
you should come inside
♪ Mountain men, I
love mountain men
♪ They're sweaty, hairy,
and hard as a rock
♪ They're taking in my
wood around the clock
♪ We finish, have a smoke,
then we go at it again
♪ 'Cause when junk gets hard
it's time for mountain men
- [Announcer] Here's an
anthem for the working class.
♪ I gotta go deep
inside a manhole
♪ Dirty, dark, old manhole
♪ Squeeze inside that manhole
♪ I do it everyday
- [Announcer] And
Steve's biggest hit
about the time his
transmission went out.
♪ I blew a tranny last night
♪ This might hurt you but
there's nothing I can do
♪ 'Cause I blew a
tranny last night
♪ I blew a tranny last night
♪ This might hurt you but
there's nothing I can do
♪ 'Cause I blew a
tranny last night
- [Announcer] Steve Williams
wholesome country music songs.
Order now.